[Applause]
suicide drone in action they've
bombarded Ukraine in recent weeks
[Music]
here police shoot one out the sky
Iran is accused of selling many of this
kind of drone to Russia
it claims it was only a small number
supplied before the war
but a Security Source has told Sky News
of a secret deal that allegedly involved
Moscow flying 140 million euros to Iran
in August in return for more than 160
drones
it wasn't just cash allegedly on the
Russian aircraft The Source said Russia
had managed to get hold of a shipment of
UK and U.S weapons that had been
intended for the ukrainians within that
captured shipment The Source said three
different weapons anti-tank and
anti-aircraft missiles were also
transported to Iran the fear is the
Iranians could try to reverse engineer
them and develop models of Their Own
The Source also shared these satellite
images allegedly showing two Russian
ilyushin il-76 aircraft marked here at
an airport in Tehran at least one was
allegedly involved in the mission
Sky News can't independently verify the
two aircraft as Russian
but we have geolocated the images to an
area on the western side of mehrabad
airport in the Iranian Capital comparing
the images with one we obtained
ourselves from the previous day we can
match up the shapes of these two hangars
the runway here and the boundary
it's also possible to see these two
other aircraft parked at the same place
in the same location
the two allegedly Russian planes are
first pictured at 1 17 am local time on
the 20th of August
by just after 3 30 a.m one of them has
moved to the runway side and the other
has turned around
in the final image three and a half
hours later they can no longer be seen
Ukraine isn't just worried about Iran's
Shahid 136 suicide drones
what we are afraid is the reports of
much more sophisticated ballistic
missiles that's around about to sell to
Russia this still have to be
investigated but this will cause a real
real threat Iran has denied the
allegation
as for Russia its previously dismissed
claims it's using Iranian drones in
Ukraine but the Security Source claimed
a new deal was finalized just a few days
ago
if true it could bring more pain from
the skies
debraham Sky News